je jouais maintenant à ottawa emmanuel
tremblay elle est la présidente de
l'association canadienne des employés
professionnels
l'un tremblay bonsoir bonsoir madame
galipeau bon on sait que c'est pas la
première fois qu'on entend les
dénonciations de la part des
scientifiques vous avez entendu le
gouvernement qui réplique que c'est
parce que vous êtes en ce moment en
négociations est ce que c'est le cas
c'est clair oui nous sommes
effectivement en négociation ce
gouvernement nous apporte sur la table
des propositions notamment sur les
congés de maladie et nous on rétorque en
disant n'y a pas vraiment d'enjeu autour
des congés de maladie et le gouvernement
essaye par tous les moyens de de dire
que ça coûte cher au contribuable et
qu'il veut changer ce régime là mais
c'est pas basé sur aucun fait donc c'est
intéressant de voir que l'intégrité
scientifique et analytique et même mise
à mal par ce par ce gouvernement quand
il arrive à la table de négociations
mais est-ce que la situation s'est
détériorée jusqu'où ça va exactement
quand vous parlez de museler les
scientifiques
c'est clair que la situation s'est
détériorée moi même qui était
fonctionnaire jusque ailleurs après à
peine quatre mois quand je suis devenu
président de mon syndicat
je l' ai vécu j'ai travaillé pour
l'agencé canadienne de développement
international puis affaires étrangères
commerce et développement jeu j'ai vu
clairement les changements et l'érosion
d'un modèle ou en tant que fonctionnaire
nous on sert le public et est ce qu'on
nous a demandé au fils des amis c'est de
servir de moins en moins le public
canadien est de plus en plus l'idéologie
conservatrice qui domine mais là est ce
que c'est vrai qu'on vous demande qu'on
va jusqu'à vous demander de de terre
certains résultats ou de modifier même
certaines données oui c'est le cas je
dire ou alors de clairement de faire en
sorte de ne pas trop mettre dans nos
avis des conseils ou ministre les
questions dont ils ne veulent pas
véritablement en entendre parler
et moi quand je suis devenu
fonctionnaire c'était avec l'intention
d'être capable de donner des conseils
courageux basée sur des données
scientifiques vérifié et c'est ce qu'on
a à ce qu'on ait de moins en moins en
train de faire on nous demande de ré
inventer des données pour soutenir des
des décisions politiques des choix
politiques de donner un exemple par
exemple il y en a plusieurs exemples moi
je sais que quand j'étais aux affaires à
l'acdi à l'époque on parlait de
l'importance de la santé maternelle puis
il ya des enjeux très clair en termes de
survie de mer par rapport au fait que
l'accès à l'avortement
c'est une manière de sauver des vies de
femmes qui ont d'autres enfants par
exemple
c'est des choses qui ne peuvent jamais
être discutée et ça c'est purement
idéologique comme approche sans ce n'est
qu'un exemple bien entendu mais un
exemple plus vaste et qui touche
l'ensemble des canadiens et canadiennes
et québécoises et québécois c'est la fin
du recensement du questionnaire long
obligatoire du recensement
ça a un impact dans la vie des gens dans
leur quotidien sans qu'il s'en rende
réellement content parce que ça enlève
des outils de décision en matière de
politique publique pour le fédéral mais
aussi pour les provinces les
municipalités même le secteur privé et
donc on parle beaucoup de la place du
canada dans le monde dont j'imagine que
les scientifiques et vous professionnels
employés professionnels donc du
gouvernement fédéral
est-ce que ça a un impact là dessus
aussi c'est clair c'est clair que le
fait pour les six que pour les
scientifiques il ne puisse partager la
leur leurs conclusions mais aussi le
fait que statistique canada avec le
recensement de 2011 a perdu par exemple
à la réputation en matière de de données
probantes pour ses politiques publiques
et l'ancien statisticien en chef
monarchie qui était la semaine dernière
à un événement où il se tirait la
sonnette d'alarmé design n'est pas trop
tard mais il ne nous reste que quelques
semaines à peine si on veut que le
canada repense à réintégrer le
questionnaire long à statistique canada
mais encore là ce n'est qu'un exemple
parmi tant d'autres
madame tremblay merci beaucoup c'est moi
qui vous remercie
je vous souhaite une très bonne soirée
merci aussi